[Música]
las calles iraníes siguen siendo el
escenario de manifestaciones masivas de
ciudadanos que rechazan la muerte de
maxa a mini cuando estaba bajo custodia
policial justamente el 13 de octubre se
cumple Ya un mes de que esta joven fuera
detenida por la llamada policía de la
moral por no llevar bien puesto el velo
islámico tres días después a mini
falleció en una estación de policía y
fue trasladada también a un hospital
donde allí fue ya declarada muerta según
las autoridades por complicaciones de
salud pero los indicios apuntan a que
murió por los golpes y el maltrato
recibido durante su detención nuestra
corresponsal entera en Catalina Gómez
Ángel nos hace un recuento de los hechos
más destacados del último mes en la
República islámica escuchemos
sin duda el sistema de la República
islámica no ha entendido incluso todavía
la dimensión de la indignación y de la
rabia que tuvo un gran sector de la
población especialmente joven y
especialmente mujer cuando se conoció lo
que había pasado con maxam y una joven
de 22 años que estaba de visita en
Teherán caminaba por la ciudad cuando
fue detenida por una de esas patrullas
de la moral y dos horas más tarde era
llevada con muerte cerebral al hospital
muchas de esas jóvenes que están en la
calle han sido víctimas también de esas
patrullas y saben que muchas veces
actúan de manera violenta y algunos
testigos aseguran que esta mujer fue
golpeada aunque las autoridades todavía
aseguran que ella murió como
consecuencia de una enfermedad que tuvo
en su infancia lo que crea mayor
indignación dentro de la población que
sigue protestando no solamente en
Teherán sino las grandes ciudades del
país y esto se hace especialmente
evidente en la región del kurdistán de
donde es originaria
donde la represión ha aumentado incluso
más en los últimos días se habla de
grandes enfrentamientos se habla de
patrullas de la policía yendo a sacar a
personas de sus casas explosiones y se
habla de menos 5000 detenidos solamente
en esa zona del país hoy hablaba el jefe
de la justicia iraní y decía que los
principales protagonistas de estas
movilizaciones de estos disturbios como
los llaman tenían que tener fuertes
sentencias que así se lo había ordenado
a sus jueces y que el resto de la
población que está así aparte de ellos
tenía que ser juzgado y salir
rápidamente pero también el debate que
se ha creado en estas últimas semanas es
el velo a estas horas muchas mujeres
caminan por las calles de Teherán y de
las grandes ciudades sin velo y el uno
de los asesores del líder supremo de la
Revolución ex portavoz del parlamento
alilar y ya ni hablaba de que si el 50%
de las mujeres no quieren usar el velo
habría que abrir esa conversación porque
no se le pueden poner a importante que
hacer Así que el debate está abierto
falta ver que dice la parte más radical
de la República islámica y saber cómo
van a seguir gestionando estas protestas
desde la muerte de
Irán ha sido testigo de un estallido
social como pocas veces ha visto ese
país manifestaciones de mujeres de
jóvenes estudiantes y más recientemente
de trabajadores del sector energético
que es digamos la espina dorsal de la
economía iraní que está seriamente
afectada por las sanciones
internacionales a todo esto cómo ha
respondido el gobierno de Irán con
represión más de 185 personas han
fallecido a lo largo de esta semana
según reporta derechos humanos de Irán
que es un grupo humanitario que tiene
sede en la ciudad de oslo en Noruega
Irán ha liberado acerca de 1700 personas
que fueron detenidas durante las
manifestaciones así lo reportó El Vocero
de la judicatura iraní masud se tallecís
pero no dio a conocer el número de
personas que han sido detenidas hasta
ahora a lo largo de este mes de
manifestaciones el gobierno también ha
respondido con la suspensión del
servicio de internet en diferentes
ciudades del país diferentes regiones y
también cortando las señales de los
medios de comunicación la represión ha
sido aún más evidente en la ciudad de
nanandag que es la capital de la
provincia del kurdistán iraní región de
donde era originaria
hoy en el debato en el debate de France
24 la rebelión del velo Hacia dónde se
dirige Irán lo vamos a analizar aquí en
unos minutos para conversar sobre este
tema hemos invitado a anahíta nazil él
ya es politóloga y analista experta en
temas iraníes también está con nosotros
rainhart la más Plus él es experto en
Irán y en derechos humanos fue
coordinador del equipo de Irán de
amnistía internacional ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden hacer parte
de este debate pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook y en instagram no se encuentran
como arroba el debate guión bajo
f-24@santilogo que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta numeral el debate
24 no olviden que todos los contenidos
de nuestro programa ya están disponibles
en diferentes plataformas de podcast
estamos en Apple podcast en Spotify en
deezer y en TuneIn
Bueno pues comienzo dándole entonces la
bienvenida a anahíta Gracias por estar
con nosotros aquí en el debate de France
24 Punto de partida estamos entonces de
acuerdo al análisis que usted puede
hacer de la situación en Irán ante una
Revolución como la hemos llamado
revolución del velo que va más allá de
ese sentir de las mujeres iraníes y
también compromete un malestar
generalizado que hay por parte de la
sociedad iraní Cuál es su análisis
Hola gracias por la invitación en efecto
Se podría decir Revolución Aunque la
verdad es que no tienen los elementos en
la revolución porque no hay un líder ha
sido un movimiento social ha sido por un
descontento por lo tanto el movimiento
Aún está en una fase muy inicial y a lo
mejor aún no se le podía Llamar
Revolución aunque creo que toda la
sociedad civil internacional tiene
muchas ganas de que eso se convierta en
una Revolución y que finalmente
de las mujeres y la sociedad civil iraní
gane mascotas de libertad Ojalá la
tendencia aunque no sea inmediata porque
la realidad es que no va a ser algo
inmediato porque el régimen no va a
soltar el poder tan fácilmente
y va a seguir reprimiendo y va a seguir
machacando la población social civil y
como lo está haciendo Y como lo poco que
nos llega porque yo estoy muy preocupada
mi familia está parte en Irán y es muy
difícil tener comunicación con ellos y
realmente las noticias son que
las fuerzas armadas la policía los
paramilitares salen a matar a la gente y
las mujeres solo tienen su valentía
su valentía que la hemos visto en las
calles de las ciudades iraníes a estas
mujeres que se enfrentan a los grupos de
las fuerzas de seguridad incluso a otros
sectores de la sociedad que están en
contra de estas manifestaciones la doy
la palabra
para conocer su opinión también El Punto
de partida si estamos ante una
revolución del velo que compromete no
solamente este reclamo por parte de las
mujeres iraníes sino también diferentes
sectores de la sociedad iraní están
reclamando un cambio en el país y lo
digo porque veíamos empleados del sector
energético también siendo partícipes de
las marchas
sí encantado de saludarles
desde el punto de vista de Derechos
Humanos lo que quisiera
destacar es
la impunidad como amenaza para los
manifestantes
que deciden el hecho de que las fuerzas
de seguridad pueden actuar en total
opacidad y con impunidad contra los
manifestantes y con los cortes de
internet por ejemplo son un elemento de
eso Entonces la organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos como amnistía
internacional
destacan que
la comunidad internacional debe tomar
medidas para frenar o para contrarrestar
esa impunidad y que que las autoridades
iraníes no puedan actuar en la en la
oscuridad en la opacidad en el corte de
internet
el tema principal
a este respecto luego en cuanto a las
consignas Y esto es mi opinión personal
no no lo digo en representación de
ninguna organización que es lo que se
percibe incluso desde desde el
extranjero es que las la gente lo que
está reclamando ya es un cambio de
sistema político y del sistema de
gobierno y separación de religión y
estado y no solo unas cuantas reformas y
la mejora de la situación económica
Sí eso lo vamos a analizar un poco más
adelante sobre ese sentir de la sociedad
iraní Anahí usted dice que todavía no se
le puede llamar a esto una Revolución no
hay un líder como tal que esté liderando
estos grupos es prácticamente espontáneo
por parte de los ciudadanos que se ponen
de acuerdo para reunirse en algún punto
de las ciudades y manifestarse pero son
muchos los factores que están
precisamente encendiendo estas
manifestaciones
Por qué específicamente el caso de maxam
Mini
la muerte de esta mujer ha despertado
tal sensibilidad en la sociedad iraní en
qué coyuntura están En qué situación
están que este fue la situación que
dijeron basta salimos a la calle
Es que de hecho la situación que le pasó
a masa es algo que le puede pasar a
cualquier mujer en Irán es decir a
partir de los siete años la mujer está
obligada a llevar velo en público y ya
depende de su de su figura paterna o el
hermano o el marido para poder ser un
miembro siempre con discriminación en la
sociedad Entonces
qué le pasara algo así a masa cada una
de las mujeres iraníes lo interpretó
como que le podía haber pasado ahí a
misma y eso se ha juntado con el
descontento que el país de Irán trae
consigo desde hace muchos años Tenemos
que tener en cuenta que Irán lleva desde
el punto de inflexión de la Revolución
islámica lleva 43 años viviendo en una
República teocrática la islámica la
única del mundo en la cual todo el poder
está concentrado en un líder
supremoney que no tiene que responder
ante nadie y no es elegido y todo el
entramado político que se ha creado a
raíz de la Revolución hace que todo pase
por El poder del líder supremo y la
gente Aunque va a votar saben que los
candidatos ya han pasado los filtros del
régimen por lo tanto el presidente
actual
en verdad no es el que toma las
decisiones más importantes y Igualmente
es uno del régimen de hecho raíz y fue
un juez que durante muchos años firmó
muchísimas sentencias de muerte por lo
tanto el contexto interior iraní es muy
complejo desde el punto de vista
político a nivel económico viven un
embargo internacional y viven una
inflación un paro disparado y la gente
tiene muy pocas expectativas de salidas
profesionales y de prometedor y por el
otro lado existe todo este entramado de
discriminación hacia la mujer que es
casi el 50% de la población
es difícil entender la situación de Irán
porque a lo largo de los años la
comunidad internacional organismos
internacionales han hecho muchos
reclamos al gobierno de los ayatos la
por el manejo que le dan a los derechos
humanos y sobre todo a los derechos de
la mujer
a este país pero sin embargo la mujer si
se compara con otros países musulmanes
en Irán Tiene ciertas ventajas o ciertas
libertades si se compara con otros
países que son musulmanes Cómo hacer ese
equilibrio que resulta yo creo muy
difícil entre la parte cultural de la
parte musulmana que tanto nos cuesta
entender en en el lado occidental y el
equilibrio de garantías de derechos
humanos y derechos hacia la mujer
ahí tengo que manifestar mi desacuerdo
sobre todo escuchando a las iraníes que
a todas las mujeres iraníes que
escuchaba sobre el tema niegan que el
velo sea un rasco cultural y sé que no
forma parte de nuestra cultura como como
un rasgo general es decir es una
elección de cada persona y las mismas
mujeres que lo dicen igual tienen madres
o hermanas que son religiosas y se lo
ponen pero lo que constantemente se
niega que sea algo cultural
y que eso se pueda usar como para
justificar la obligatoriedad entonces la
lucha está contra la obligatoriedad y lo
que se reprocha Es que en la cuestión
del velo desde occidente con una
perspectiva que se suele Llamar
orientalismo se ensalce como algo
que hay que respetar entre comillas y
hay que
igual que criticar demasiado porque al
final no hay que discriminar esa cultura
que es otra cultura y contra ese
relativismo se dirigen
el policías incluso diciendo que no que
no es nuestra cultura y queremos ser
libres de elegir como como queremos ir
por la calle
anaíta su opinión sobre este tema del
pelo desde el punto occidental pues es
visto como sí algo que hay que respetar
hay mucho reclamos al gobierno de Irán
por el respeto a los derechos humanos y
a los derechos de las mujeres pero pero
según la opinión de rainhart es un
factor que no es tan cultural Pero
entonces ella porque fue detenida Si
llevaba el velo mal puesto
es que entran en muchos elementos en
juego de hecho él ya para Irán Yo creo
que es ahora representa el símbolo de la
de todo el descontento y de las ganas de
cambio de las mujeres en Irán pero a las
mujeres sirenas iraní se les preguntas
muchas veces el tema del velo no aparece
como una prioridad antes esta tener más
libertad tener más cuotas de libertad de
política o social o tener expectativas
de vida poderse casar y vivir con el
marido como todo el mundo lo que
queremos en el mundo sí que es verdad
que el velo en la época del chat antes
de la Revolución como el ya era muy
occidental el velo no casi lo llevaban
Muy pocas personas mayores en ciudades
muy pequeñas son pueblos cuando hubo la
revolución el pañuelo se convirtió en un
elemento simbólico contra Elsa porque
como la contraposición Asimismo en una
segunda etapa de la Revolución el velo
se convirtió en un elemento contra
occidente para diferenciarse de lo que
había sido toda la herencia del chat y
justo después de la Revolución y en los
años siguientes había como una un
concepto comunitario de el velo
solamente
que es una opción personal o es
obligatorio solamente las mezquitas pero
el pañuelo era como una representación
de símbolo de la Revolución y fue lo que
permitió que la mujer saliera del ámbito
privado al ámbito público que era uno de
los objetivos de la Revolución
evidentemente todos los principios de la
Revolución se han tergiversado con la
interpretación y con el mal uso de la
del régimen que ha hecho los ayatolas
continuó con usted para hacer la ronda
diversas llevamos solamente un mes desde
que fue detenida esta joven iraní y que
dio inicio a todas estas manifestaciones
tras su muerte Tal vez es muy temprano
para decirlo pero
viéndolas a ellas a las mujeres iraníes
en las calles sin el velo desafiando a
la autoridad desafiando al régimen si se
le puede llamar así es un parte de aguas
para la historia iraní para la
Revolución y para la sociedad iraní cree
usted que estamos ante el inicio de un
nuevo capítulo en donde las mujeres
iraníes van a reclamar su posición en la
sociedad de iraní como debe ser según
ellas
Yo quiero decir sí que Ojalá sea
realmente el punto de inflexión para una
nueva etapa de la historia de Irán eso
no quiere decir que a pesar de la
increíble valentía de estas mujeres que
tienen todo un estado represor que aún
no ha sacado toda la fuerza que puede
sacar para reprimirlas y ella solo
tienen su valentía para ponerse delante
de esas armas
no será hoy no será mañana a lo mejor
serán unos años pero sí que es verdad
que algo es el principio del fin del
régimen tal cual el régimen
existe y es como como lo entendemos
hasta ahora por lo tanto yo quiero
pensar que sí Hay que seguir dando voz a
estas mujeres increíblemente valientes
Hay que seguir dando voz a todo lo que
pueda permitir que se investiguen todas
las violaciones de Derechos Humanos que
se están dando en Irán
y tenemos que creer y tenemos que estar
apoyándolas porque puede ser realmente
el comienzo de una nueva era para Irán
Cuál es su opinión Este es el inicio un
nuevo capítulo en la historia de Irán
del presente de este país y el futuro en
donde las mujeres pueden tener una
posición más destacada
sí Estoy totalmente de acuerdo con la
que acabo de decir anahíta
solo quisiera Añadir que del punto de
vista de los humanos también lo ha
amenazado naita es importante también
evitar la impunidad que se investiguen
todos los crímenes de violaciones de
Derechos Humanos
Y como por ejemplo
se va a hacer en el tribunal de avant
que va a tener lugar en
noviembre en
las instituciones europeas
Entonces
es importante que que no
pasen sin establecer y sin que haya
justicia sin que se haga justicia
estos años de estos 40 años de de
República islámica
la respuesta del gobierno de Irán a
estas manifestaciones ciudadanas ha sido
la represión ya lo mencionábamos han
cortado el servicio de internet sobre
todo en la región del kurdistán iraní
han cortado también la señal de algunos
medios de comunicación
es difícil comunicarse dentro del país y
también para los familiares de la de los
iraníes que viven por fuera de las
fronteras iraníes amnistía internacional
y también la Casa Blanca han criticado
la violencia contra los manifestantes
qué más respuesta puede haber de la
comunidad internacional porque tal
parece entendería uno que están
simplemente dejando que las cosas fluyan
porque esto podría provocar un colapso
del régimen como lo vio usted
desde el punto de vista de
organizaciones y activistas Derechos
Humanos no tenemos más medios que hacer
llamamientos y y de dirigirnos a los a
los políticos y los gobiernos
no tenemos más medios depresión que esos
pero sí que que queremos hacer un
llamamiento que que se haga presión
sobre las autoridades
presionar las autoridades
sí adelante adelante
para no sigan reprimiendo para que no
haya impunidad y
sobre todo que no haya esa
oscuridad de los cortes de internet que
favorece la comisión de delitos
a ver si podemos entender aquí un punto
importante y es bueno la represión ha
sido la respuesta del gobierno a
impunidad por supuesto por parte de la
justicia para algunos casos
a lo largo de Los años lo hemos visto
así y Tal parece que el gobierno iraní
tiene poca capacidad de diálogo sobre
todo cuando no tiene mucho para ofrecer
en una negociación entonces estas
manifestaciones A qué puerto pueden
llegar cuando el gobierno no se muestra
abierto a escuchar a Los manifestantes a
las mujeres y a los ciudadanos o la
sociedad en general y las
manifestaciones continúan la represión
entonces segui el arma a usar
es que claro yo creo que el régimen se
ha encontrado con un poco el pie
torcido porque no se esperaba
una situación así y de hecho en las
anteriores protestas como en 2009 o
2017/2019 también reprimió a la
población y a las protestas de hecho en
2019 fue la primera vez cortaron el
acceso a internet no solamente para
aislar a los iraníes internamente sino
sobre todo para que los de la comunidad
internacional no supera cómo se estaba
llevando a cabo esa represión tan
violenta entonces con Irán es muy
difícil saber exactamente cómo Cuáles
van a ser los siguientes pasos o lo que
va a ocurrir una cosa es lo que todos
deseamos también un inciso es diferente
lo que decidimos o lo que deseamos los
iraníes que llevamos ya mucho tiempo
fuera de Irán con lo que realmente
desean los iraníes de dentro que son
ellos los que tienen que decidir Su
futuro nosotros desde fuera tenemos que
dar voz y tenemos que apoyarles de
acompañarles pero yo creo que el régimen
tal como está estructurado el
sometimiento y la discriminación
sistemática La mujer la van a tener que
seguir manteniendo porque si no se
resquebrajería realmente su estructura
su esencia siempre se ha dicho que quién
puede cuestionar el régimen en Irán
serían las mujeres los jóvenes y los
grupos étnicos porque hay que tener en
cuenta que los persas son menos del 50%.
Sí claro y son justamente los que están
saliendo en su mayoría de las calles los
estudiantes las mujeres y en este caso
los kurdos que están en el
nor occidente de ese país y que es una
región que abarca también algunas partes
del norte de Irak incluso del este de
Turquía
rainhartt seguimos hablando del tema de
la represión y de los Derechos Humanos
ahora pues lo titulamos en los medios de
comunicación lo vemos en occidente como
una respuesta que llama la atención por
parte de Irán no va a decir si Bueno ni
mala es la forma en que el gobierno
simplemente responde a estas
manifestaciones Pero esto no es nuevo en
Irán desde 1979 desde que comenzó la
revolución el miedo y la represión ha
sido el instrumento vertical para
sostener la la Revolución islámica por
qué no se ha hecho nada al respecto
es la gran pregunta así nosotros no nos
ocupamos de analizar los los factores
políticos que puede haber detrás de la
inacción nosotros nos dedicamos a
denunciarla en acción pero claro no no
tenemos en nuestras manos las palancas
del poder para para
a imponer
cosas es decir que nosotros en vez
pronunciamos
peticiones
recomendaciones etcétera entonces
la razón de la inacción de los puedes
políticos occidentales por ejemplo
por este muy
de tipo muy variado de que puede ser
intereses económicos geopolíticos
etcétera Pero son cuestiones en las que
nosotros no no intervenimos como
activistas de Derechos Humanos
justamente hablando del miedo algunos
medios occidentales han citado algunos
jóvenes iraníes que están tanto en el
lado iraquí como en el lado iraní de la
frontera
a lo largo de estos de esta semanas de
inestabilidad allí en el kurdistán iraní
y decían que anteriormente le tenían
miedo a este régimen al gobierno de los
ayatolá pero que ahora el muro del
terror se ha derrumbado ya nadie les
tiene miedo pero el régimen no se va a
derrumbar qué piensa usted anaíta
es que es muy difícil realmente la gente
ha perdido miedo durante 40 años han
vivido bajo una imposición de un régimen
muy estricto con unas normas que
sometían y oprimían a la mitad de la
población la mujeres sí que no tenían
derechos y Siguen sin tener derechos
Entonces el régimen va a morir matando
no sabemos si el régimen va a caer como
tal Es verdad que ahora la gente en la
calle en las calles de Irán están
pidiendo un cambio de
régimen ya no es un poquito más de
apertura o que la patrulla de la moral
sea más laxa no están realmente
planteando un cambio de régimen por lo
tanto el paradigma que se puede
presentar en breve o a corto medio plazo
Es realmente incierto tanto para los de
dentro como para la comunidad
internacional que también existen como
ha dicho Rey hard todo el tema de la
importancia geoestratégica de Irán que
es uno de los países con reservas de
petróleo y gas en el mundo y ahora que
Rusia ya no es tan Aliado de occidente
hay muchos temas que se cruzan y por un
lado la comunidad internacional sobre
todo desde la sociedad civil y las
entidades de Derechos Humanos
denuncian todo lo que se está llevando a
cabo en Irán pero por el otro lado a
nivel
de lobbies y a nivel de intereses
económicos hay otro lenguaje realmente y
no todo el mundo quiere que Irán se
convierta en una democracia en la zona
ni quieren que sea el verdadero
depositario de su de sus reservas de gas
y de petróleo o que se desestabilice aún
más también les interesa que haya cierta
estabilidad en la zona para garantizar
seguridad en esa zona que es
prácticamente la puerta de hacia central
continuó con usted anaíta para
preguntarle estamos hablando hace unos
minutos de categorías de los kurdos que
vemos la situación que tienen en el este
de Turquía vemos como la situación o fue
la situación de ellos en Irak durante el
gobierno de San José Cómo viven los
kurdos en Irán en el día de hoy Son una
minoría que tiene garantías como
cualquier otro ciudadano iraní o tienen
cierta represión por parte del gobierno
Cómo viven ellos
por ejemplo el curtista iraní es un gran
feudo de la izquierda y es uno de los
que más cuestionan al régimen durante
todo este tiempo también Es verdad que
son sunitas A diferencia de la mayoría
en Irán que son chiquitas y entonces
exceptuando enteran y en el kurdistán
les es muy difícil encontrar mezquitas
de su credo Por otra parte no tienen los
mismos derechos que el resto de la
población Chita un sonido puede
presentarse a candidato para ser
presidente de la de la República por
ejemplo por lo que ellos no pueden
estudiar en su idioma tienen pueden
hablar su idioma pero no pueden educarse
en su idioma por lo tanto existe toda
una serie de y no solamente de los
kurdos ella feliz hay Turco turkmenos
Hay muchísimas otras pequeñas etnias que
viven en Irán y que se sienten
discriminadas el kurdistán además de del
por el volumen de población y por las
zonas estratégica que se encuentra
también todo el mundo es consciente de
que lo que pasa en el curtista ni iraní
se puede
difundir también al kurdistán de Irak y
de Turquía los kurdos hay que recordar
que son el único pueblo del mundo que no
tiene un estado y por lo tanto lo que
les pase a ellos o la autonomía el grado
de autonomía que puedan lograr podría
producir un efecto en carne en cadena en
el resto de zonas donde viven otros
kurdos
regresó con usted ahora para preguntarle
por la situación de los medios de
comunicación en Irán Y por qué Porque ni
lo farjamedic que es una periodista
iraní fue ella la encargada de publicar
para el medio de comunicación para que
ella trabaja de la foto de los papás de
Max a mini abrazados en el hospital en
minutos después de haber recibido la
noticia que su hija había fallecido esto
obviamente no le gustó al gobierno
gobierno iraní y esta periodista ya está
arrestada también obviamente tres días
después fue arrestada y a lo largo de
este mes 28 periodistas iraníes han sido
detenidos por las autoridades por
reportar las manifestaciones y Por
investigar sobre este caso y profundizar
un poco en la situación de la mujer
iraní los medios de comunicación también
copados por el gobierno la gente no
tiene como informarse allí en este país
a lo largo de estos años qué garantía se
le pueden dar a los iraníes para
informarse libremente
los activistas sobre todo recibe
activistas reclaman que los países
occidentales y las grandes compañías
tecnológicas
pongan a disposición de los iraníes
medios para eludir la censura es decir
que pongan que vuelquen todo su poderío
tecnológico y y político en ayuda
estructural a empoderar a los iraníes
para poder informarse
por su propia cuenta ya que los medios
de comunicación como usted acaba de
decir en Irán están controlados por por
las autoridades y no hay libertad de
expresión
Entonces
es una triste tradición que Irán es uno
de los países con más tasa de
periodistas encarcelados en todo el
mundo
es una realidad a la que tienen allí muy
complicada una realidad que tienen los
periodistas en Irán así lo dicen los
diferentes rankings a nivel mundial
vamos llegando ya el bloque final del
programa quiero hacer entonces las
conclusiones comienzo con rainhat de lo
que podemos ver en las próximas semanas
más manifestaciones más represión
posibilidades de acercamientos entre las
partes o definitivamente va bajando la
marea y el y la efervescencia entre los
ciudadanos y esto se tranquiliza o se
profundiza
hay una tendencia muy preocupante que es
la persecución de menores hoy el mismo
salió un informe la amnistía
internacional sobre 23 menores
asesinados por las fuerzas de seguridad
y que ya han muerto 23 niños y niñas que
se manifestaban y otro hecho también muy
preocupante el anuncio por parte de unos
uno de los dignatarios de Irán
de representantes del régimen de
internar a
manifestantes menores en centros
de
psicoterapéuticos
psiquiátricos para tratarlos para que no
desarrollen
problemas anti actitudes antisociales es
decir que eso es muy preocupante
entonces lo que vamos a ver seguro es
como ahora la olea de las de las
manifestaciones ha aprendido Mecha en
los en los Colegios hasta niños
ya es muy muy tempranas se ve bien
manifestándose lo que vamos a ver Es más
represión contra menores y más Víctimas
de menores el punto de vista de nuestro
invitado finalizó entonces con anaíta la
conclusión final para el cierre del
programa adelante
seguramente el régimen como he dicho
antes va a seguir matando y va a seguir
reprimiendo eso sí no puedes matar a
toda una población o a la multitud de
gente si las revueltas y la
manifestaciones siguen adelante llegar
al momento que el régimen pueda colapsar
evidentemente no es inmediato y hay que
seguir dando voz y esperemos que la
próxima vez que se hable de Irán sea
porque se ha conseguido producir algún
cambio ojalá pues Seguiremos muy atentos
a lo que vaya sucediendo a lo largo de
los próximos días allí en la República
islámica hemos estado reportando día a
día lo que sucede allí en estas
manifestaciones anteriormente ya hicimos
otro programa del debate justamente para
hablar del papel de la mujer en ese país
y entender lo que significa la mujer en
la sociedad iraní y pues aquí Seguiremos
anadita reportando lo que suceda allí en
su país es todo por el momento en parte
del equipo técnico Les agradecemos su
sintonía a anahíta y arrancar Les
agradecemos por haber estado con
nosotros en el programa de hoy la
producción del de este programa estuvo a
cargo de Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera y Samuel Salgado Gracias por
estar con nosotros Siguen con frase 24
[Música]